Die Miss-Germany-Wahl 2018!
22 Frauen wollen die Krone,
nur eine bekommt sie.
Hinter der Bühne haben die Hairstylisten
alle Hände voll zu tun –
mit Wicklern, Lockenstäben, Fön
und sehr langen Haaren.
Nur eine kann sich entspannen, denn
ihre Frisur sitzt immer:
Ioanna Palamarcuk, die als amtierende
Miss Niedersachsen an den Start geht.
Sie ist nicht nur backstage eine
kleine Sensation.
Eine Kandidatin mit rasiertem Kopf –
das hat es hier noch nie gegeben.
Eine Sonderbehandlung gab es für sie
trotzdem nicht.
In den Vorbereitungswochen hat sie sich
mit ihren Konkurrentinnen gut verstanden.
Es sind ja nur Haare,
es ist ja – es sind nur kurze Haare,
es ist ja nichts Schlimmes und ...
Ich glaube, wir …
Unsere Persönlichkeiten
haben einfach zusammengepasst,
und das war das, was gezählt hat.
Drei Wochen zuvor:
Ioanna Palamarcuk packt die Koffer für
das Abenteuer Miss-Germany-Wahl.
Ihre radikale Frisur hat sie noch gar
nicht so lange.
Vor Kurzem sah sie so aus.
Mit dem neuen Look kam auch der Mut.
Die Anmeldung zur ersten Miss Wahl in
ihrer Heimatstadt Hannover
war gar nicht so ernst gemeint, aber
sie gewann tatsächlich.
Ich hab‘ mir da jetzt keine großen
Gedanken drüber gemacht,
dass ich das gewinnen möchte oder
ähnliches,
sondern ich hab‘ einfach mitgemacht,
um es auszuprobieren, um meine
Erfahrungen zu sammeln
und einfach nur Spaß zu haben.
Doch der Ehrgeiz war geweckt.
Dabei gehörte ihre Leidenschaft bislang
nicht dem Modeln, sondern dem Tanzen.
Das Studio von Olando, ihrem Mentor,
ist ihre zweite Heimat.
Nach der Wahl zur Miss Niedersachsen
gab es für die junge Frau eine Menge Kritik
- wegen der Frisur.
In den sozialen Netzwerken wurde sie
regelrecht beschimpft:
sie sei hässlich, sehe aus wie ein Junge
und krebskrank.
Aber das hat sie offenbar nur
stärker gemacht.
Ich meine, es ist okay, dass ihr
eure Meinung habt.
Danke dafür.
Aber,
ja… so what.
Ist nicht mein Problem, alles gut.
Aber in den Wochen vor der Wahl
war sie
- wie alle -  auf sich allein gestellt.
Auf der kanarischen Insel Fuerteventura
gab es für die Teilnehmerinnen
Fitness- und Medientraining und
professionelle Fotoshootings.
Die Kandidatinnen wurden
rundum betreut.
Und die 17 Jahre alte Schülerin
aus Hannover
verwandelte sich in einen
extravaganten Vamp.
Wenige Minuten vor dem Finale der
Miss-Germany-Wahl:
Ihre langhaarigen Mitstreiterinnen
mögen sie,
aber räumen sie ihr auch Chancen ein?
Sie ist was ganz Außergewöhnliches
mit den kurzen Haaren,
sie sticht ja wirklich sofort raus.
Man guckt durch die Mädels durch
und bämm, da ist Ioanna.
Und ich glaub‘ auf jeden Fall, dass
sie definitiv ins Finale kommt, ja.
Auch wie sie ihre Geschichte weitergibt,
also auch mit dem ganzen Hintergrund,
dass sie gemobbt wurde,
dass sie so fiese Kommentare
gegen den Kopf bekommen hat.
Und das ist einfach Wahnsinn, mit was
für einer Persönlichkeit sie hier steht.
Kurze Haare, lange Haare,
also ich finde, das is[t] alles offen.
Ob die Jury das auch so sieht, stellt
sich jetzt heraus.
Aber hier scheint das Schönheitsideal
bei einigen noch sehr streng zu sein.
Im Gesichtsbereich ist es der sogenannte
„Goldene Schnitt“,
also die Augenabstände müssen stimmen,
dann der Nasen-Kinn-Winkel,
etwa 110 Grad, Körbchengröße B – C
maximal,
keine Cellulite.
Ja, und Bodymass…
Die Schülerin aus Hannover glänzt
im Abendkleid
- auch ohne volle Haarpracht. Ioanna
hat sich vorgenommen,
allem entspannt entgegenzusehen.
Nächster Durchgang: Bademode.
Und direkt bei der ersten Entscheidung des
Abends gibt es für sie eine Enttäuschung.
Sie schafft es nicht in die engere Auswahl
und scheidet aus.
Am Ende des Abends wird eine andere
die Krone tragen.
Die neue Miss Germany 2018 wird die
23 Jahre alte Anahita Rehbein,
eine Studentin aus Stuttgart.
Bei Ioanna fließen neben der Bühne
jetzt doch noch Tränen.
Aber vor Rührung.
Denn viele gratulieren ihr trotzdem für
ihren Auftritt und ihren Mut.
Erstmal geht‘s Montag natürlich
zur Schule,
so das Alltägliche wieder.
Aber jetzt kann ich das machen,
was ich machen möchte,
das machen, was mir Spaß macht.
Und ich schau‘ einfach,
wo mich der Weg hinführt.
Ihr Weg als Miss Germany 2018
dürfte für das nächste Jahr dagegen
vorgezeichnet sein.
Und übrigens …
mit der Krone wäre es ohne lange
Haare auch schwierig geworden.
Die muss nämlich festgesteckt werden.